PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Are you
getting lots of questions
from your customers
related to COVID-19?
In this video, I will
walk through the steps
to help you build and implement
a rapid response virtual agent.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
As the world responds
to the COVID-19 crisis,
providing your
customers with accurate,
timely information
is crucial to keeping
people safe and informed.
You can use the template in
this tutorial to set up a custom
rapid response voice and
chat virtual agent that
integrates directly into
your web, phone, social,
and message channels.
You can launch it in
23 different languages.
And it's available for any
organization, including
health care and public
services, government agencies,
and nonprofits, as well
as other industries that
are severely impacted, including
travel, financial services,
and retail.
Let's take a look at how you can
get started using the template.
Your first step is to download
the Dialogflow COVID-19 agent
template from GitHub
link in the description.
To create the agent, navigate
to dialogflow.cloud.google.com,
log in, and click
Create New Agent.
Give your agent a name,
and then click Create.
Now, click on the gear
icon on the right-hand side
of the new agent.
Under Export and Import,
select Import from ZIP,
and drop the ZIP file that you
just downloaded from GitHub.
Now you're ready to
import and set up
the back end for your agent.
And for that, you
deploy fulfillment.
Go back to the GitHub and
download the Dialogflow
COVID-19 fulfillment.
Back in the Dialogflow
console, click fulfillment
in the left sidebar
and toggle the switch
to enable the inline editor.
You'll be asked to enable a
billing account in Google Cloud
console.
When you're ready,
navigate to Cloud Functions
from the left panel.
Under Source code, select
the ZIP upload, and upload
the ZIP file that
you got from GitHub.
Now you should see
three intents--
closure, confirmed
cases, and deaths.
That requires setting up
Google Map's API and BigQuery
API for metrics.
Let's enable the
BigQuery API first.
Select the APIs and services
from the left panel.
Then click on Enable
APIs and services.
Search for BigQuery
API and enable it.
For the Maps API, you will
need to create credentials.
To do that, click
on Credentials.
Create credentials,
and then API key.
Make sure to restrict the key
to Cloud Functions API only.
Now, back in our
Cloud Function, we
need to set this API key
as an environment variable.
For that, edit the
Cloud Function.
Click on the environment
variables and add the variable.
The name should be
GOOGLE_MAPS_API_KEY.
And then the value should be
the API key you just created.
And then just deploy.
Now you're ready to test.
The easiest way to do that is
to test in Dialogflow simulator.
Let's try an example.
Is it still safe to
receive packages?
The response should
indicate that you set up
your agent correctly.
If you plan on enabling
the bot on your website,
go to the integration
section on the left panel
and enable Dialogflow Messenger.
Copy this code snippet and
add it to your website.
You can also use the Try It
Now button to test it out.
Let's say I select
Start Screening.
The agent starts asking
me for specific symptoms
and directs me
based on my answers.
If you want to enable this
experience via telephone,
go to the integrations, select
Dialogflow Phone Gateway
and a phone number.
Place a call to the
number and test it out.
If you want to interact
with the Dialogflow API,
you will need to create
a service account
and download the private key.
Here's how you would do that.
Go to the IAM in admin
on the left panel
and select Service Accounts.
Create a new service account.
Give your new account a name.
The role would be project owner.
And then click
Create, Create Key
will let you download the
JSON key on your computer.
You will use this file
in your environment.
So save it.
Open the terminal on
your local machine
or any other interface where
you can run a call command.
Execute export Google
application credentials,
which would be equal to the
location of your key file
in quotations.
So make sure you provide
the right location.
To test, we will
need a user request.
Let's say the user asks,
how can I get tested.
We put that in a file
called request.JSON.
And next, we will
send this request
to Dialogflow detect intent
API using the code command
with post request
option authorization
header that gets the token
value via gcloud auth command.
And then, the data gets
parsed as request.JSON.
And there you have a
response in JSON format.
All that's left
is to parse it out
and do what you need to do with
it in your custom application.
[? Current ?] is
just an example.
You can interact
with the Dialogflow
API using other
language integrations,
like Python, Java, et cetera.
Refer to the
documentation linked below
for language of your choice.
And that's it.
We hope you and your customers
will find the Rapid Response
Virtual Agent helpful during
this unprecedented time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]